you look like the worst Power Ranger
really yeah you look like the
non-athletic Power Ranger you look like
the only Power Ranger that can't fight
using cost you your Parenthood as a book
bag okay the Power Rangers I wants to
talk about it has hundreds [ __ ] just
dance and hashtag no races you gotta
[ __ ] jump ropes backwards only dude
oh there's no brown-nose dude bro you
look like a [ __ ] I look like a shower
Ranger okay the only woman that really
needs a shower you might have a
ridiculous ass but you always have baggy
clothes on we don't know you're right
just like Roseanne Texas bro you look
really o'donnell sidepiece you guys have
the same stylist characters that just
shows up on drugs like everybody else is
like the red line the red strawberry the
the green banana and you're the [ __ ]
banana that [ __ ] left home early you
you look like one of those people from
breaking Amish that leaves and [ __ ]
comes back a week later all ten just
experienced everything in one week I got
a great time you got 60 tats what a
bunch of bad shirts a couple fake roly's
and suddenly you don't know how to use a
shovel anymore go get some [ __ ]
shrimp so smoking cigarettes go get a
shrimp get everyone here shrimp I'm
trying to quit smoking cigarettes and
you look like bubble lump dude you
you look like someone broke into your
body and just sprayed a bunch of [ __ ]
drywall in your Heat you look like
Security ass it'll break you look like
your whole face is soundproof dude you
get ass bestest poisoning from your own
fat cells you dress like you only fly in
spirit anyway I'll give you that you
have the most frequent flyer miles on
Spirit Airlines dude spirit is crazy
one guy didn't have a seat that is tied
with a wall just hang on my bus
[Music]
dude you sound like a fat ambulance that
didn't make the [ __ ] sports team at
school yeah dude howdy partner
he's like an angel I was like nine tires
on it and all of them are kind of flat
on peds for hiding your seat man you
definitely think like that dude why are
you hiding over there but where the
horses get their medicine well how are
you hiding my mom's beets well yeah you
the type of dude that watches film
before he plays dodgeball breaking down
the film before you play freeze tag yeah
hi Geoff is pretty good he's not still
look at him he's gentle man yeah show me
a dirty player he's good at the tag
fries he's got nothing on me God bro
yeah and if father was a mime huh it's
just not genetic you know did you it you
look like you cheetah
Red Rover Red Rover really remember that
game yeah
God kid's gonna play it no more why not
oh it's illegal in schools yeah are you
a DJ it's like a DJ at a rave right dude
you look [ __ ] Wyatt slurp bro you
look like a cop at a freaking bathhouse
dude DJ at a rave
[ __ ] dip slow I'm so used to you not
telling good joke almost didn't even
listen to that bro you sheriff at a
[ __ ] transgender lemonades name I get
out
there's a snake in my butt you're like
you're like Steve Irwin but the gay one
you look like the first NASA astronaut
who's transgender going to space oh dude
it's a big leap on going one way for
mankind
I'm going straight into somebody's
wiener bro that's where I'm going
yeah then they take off their helmets
and it's five lesbians dude yeah there
were cuts yeah they're not being lesbian
bro here's that here's why be a lesbian
one I thought you were you can still
wear the same [ __ ] you were do you were
this exact outfit about definitely like
your their masks I'm not Brendan your
crazy brother where'd you read that
[Laughter]
Rosie O'Donnell sidepiece everything you
look like somebody who showed up in a
hardhat to work at a skill crane [ __ ]
make me a 6-inch sub you call me would
you [ __ ] no dude if you're woody apply
bro that is for sure dude you're a teak
bro you ain't no mahogany dog that's for
damn sure
you're something you're that IKEA would
you like an actual who got cut from Star
Trek didn't make this ba hey ba Star
Trek
they're like I want another movie I'm
like okay I wanna be your star tree so
uh that's good less gay okay whatever
man-- did if you pulled me over dude I
would put the cuffs on you bro that's
for sure I would tase you dude cuff me
up oh wow leave me up bro you got a
partner
how could you wear that much yellow and
just be okay when you leave the house
what do you mean what do you mean dude
what's wrong with you I can't work that
much yellow you have a yellow watch you
have a yellow hat well this is gold but
sorry like an old whatever it's so
yellow yellow yeah dude you yellow
you're in sweats head to toe never now
sorry is it sweat Friday okay everyone
get the memo and the email address like
[ __ ] I'm sorry are you flying spirit
dude you look like you picked your
outfit out from that place where you
trade in tickets at Dave & Buster's
you look like a lifeguard of a junkyard
sure I do look like that you look like
Patrick Swayze you got caught a tanning
bed
you look like fatrick Swayze twinks dude
you look like Kevin Bacon's we grew up
in Chernobyl that's what that tattoo
looks like where'd you get the head in
the Lion King gift shop that people are
ruining they go in danger people are
basically in the woods chanting you're
the last one you like when a rock you
look I got Eclair that Romeo Crennel had
for breakfast you know you've been
through some things what are you doing
okay I'm fantastic who are you again
what costume is it dude I'm woody and
you're buzz light gear never heard of
either one of them okay so I don't know
what you are do but it is just really
alarming dude you just think you're an
astronaut do you look like Dallas
returners club dude like somebody got a
refund
yeah look like you're going through some
stuff brah no I'm a mirror I can't see
my outfit dude
no you look warm you look sweet dude the
wings are kind of heavy though yeah
they're super depressing
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching